[Music]
my at 6pm yesterday evening you were
executed and pronounced dead you no
longer exist what kind of prison is this
it's not a prison you're about to enter
the animus what you're about to see hear
and feel are the memories of your
ancestor who has been dead for 500 years
what are you from me your past
welcome to the Spanish Inquisition God
even though I'm a man of God
[Applause]
will work in the dark just sort of
delight we are assassins
you
hey youtubers it's Charlie so they just
dropped the first assassin's creed
trailer if you guys didn't know this is
really like an amalgam of a lot of the
earlier movies with Michael Fassbender
marion cotillard is going to be awesome
since about assassins creed 3 the
franchise has been on auto by status for
me but it seems like they've done with
this movie is take some of the best
parts of the franchise in like a lot of
the subsequent games just play around in
the universe so if you played any of the
games a lot of this will seem familiar
if you've never played any of the games
obviously Michael Fassbender playing one
of the protagonists he's part of the
assassins order their enemies are the
Templars which is marion cotillard and
jeremy irons they are the ones using the
animus technology the animus chair which
i'll explain in a second just in case
you've never heard of it before trying
to find the weakness of the assassins
order through genetic memories so there
is a certain time travel aspect to the
film using the animus chair but you're
exploring genetic memory they're not
actually traveling back in time Michael
Fassbender is playing aquas so a lot of
what you see in this trailer does mirror
the time jumping arc of that first game
where you start in modern day and this
person seems really crazy the desmond
character Michael Fassbender then he
learns about the history of his family
and this assassins order and learns
about it using the animus chair using
genetic memory so all the super badass
flashback scenes that we see in the
Spanish Inquisition a lot of that comes
from the second game and brotherhood so
a lot of you notice that the animus
chair looks a little bit different than
it does in the video games the reason
they did this is so that in modern day
as he's accessing that genetic memory
for the first time learning about all
these skills that he has he can actually
jump around and start doing them so it
just looks a little more badass on
screen it's a lot more passive in the
video games are you just lying in that
chair like you're going to sleep or
something so I'm totally cool with them
changing the Animus part of the recall
process is them strapping the hidden
blades like that signature weapon to the
assassins tomb as they put them in the
animus this is aaron lebed there's a
number of female characters throughout
the Assassin's Creed series she might be
a version of EV the difference between
her and EV is that Eevee's from
syndicate and that's during victorian
times and Great Britain this is during
the Spanish Inquisition so way way
further back in time let me know what
you guys think about the trailer though
I'm pretty excited about the movie the
music is a little bit weird but this
just being the teaser trailer I think
they wanted people who had no idea what
was going on with the video game to be
able to connect with it in some way so
they're using a little bit of pop music
so probably change it up and put some
more hardcore
music in the next big trail if they drop
for those of you wondering about the
next big Assassin's Creed game there's
rumors that it might go back to ancient
Egypt some of the developers have said
they want to go back to the 10th century
so they're still trying to figure that
out they just released syndicate so I'm
not really expecting to hear too much
about the next game for at least another
six months but what's going to happen
next is they just announced a bunch of
big stuff so Supergirl is officially
coming to the CW now that is a done deal
I just saw a post as I was making this
video and we have Voltron to talk about
I'm so excited about Voltron this summer
so be sure to subscribe to get
everything if you guys want me to do
more assassins creed history videos just
let me know is gonna be such an awesome
summer I'm so excited where you guys
wait for my next video to post you can
click here to catch up on game of
thrones and you can click here for this
week's episode of the flash thank you so
much watching everybody let's high five
I'll see you guys tonight
you